GUIDELINES MAY BE WORKING, BUT
THE GOVERNOR THERE WARNS THE
STATE SHOULD NOT DECLARE VICTORY
JUST YET.
OUR REPORTERS ARE FANNED OUT
ACROSS, HERE WITH ME ON PIER 90
IN NEW YORK CITY AND GOOD
AFTERNOON TO YOU.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
WE ARE STILL WAITING FOR THE
FIRST PATIENCE TO ARRIVE ON THE
COMFORT.
IN THOSE PATIENCE ARE EXPECTED
TO BE THERE BY THE END OF THE
DAY AND RIGHT NOW IT’S A BIT OF
A SLOW ROLL BUT ONCE THE PROCESS
IS SET, THEY WERE EXPECTING SOME
50 PATIENTS A DAY TO BE ADMITTED
ON BOARD.
STATE HEALTH OFFICIALS AND
OFFICIALS COME TOGETHER AND THEY
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
SHOULD BE TREATED ON BOARD THE
SHIP.
AN AMBULANCE WILL THEN BRING
THEM TO THE COMFORT AFTER THEY
ARE CHECKED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY DO NOT HAVE COVID-19 BY THE
HOSPITAL AND THEN SCREENED ONCE
MORE.
THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS SITUATION
ON BOARD.
THEY ARE TREATING EVERYTHING AS
THOUGH EVERYONE ON BOARD HAS
COVID-19 CREATED THE STAFF IS
READY WITH THE BEST PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT AND DO NOT
WANT THIS TO SPREAD AT ALL.
THE GOVERNMENT IS TAKING CARE OF
THIS WITH HUMANITARIAN EMERGENCY
EMERGENCY.
WILL NOT BE ACCEPTING VISITORS
ON BOARD.
BOTTOM LINE IS WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT SOMEONE THOUSAND HOSPITAL
BEDS, AT THEIR GREATEST ASSETS
OF THE 1200 MEDICAL PERSONNEL,
NURSES, SURGEONS, DOCTORS FROM
UP AND DOWN THE EAST COAST OF
WHEN YOU TALK TO THEM, THEY’RE
USED TO HELPING OUT OTHER
COUNTRIES ON HUMANITARIAN TRIPS.
AT THE MERCY AND THE COMFORT BUT
THERE IS A SPECIAL PRIDE THEY
ARE FEELING HERE IN NEW YORK
HARBOR TO HELP US.
>> TWO WEEKS EARLY.
IN THE MEANTIME ACROSS TOWN,
CENTRAL PARK IS SETTING UP TENTS
TENTS.
>> SAMARITAN’S, THAT
ORGANIZATION HAS SET UP A FIELD
HOSPITAL IN CENTRAL PARK A
REMARKABLE SITE.
THEY WERE EXPECTING PATIENTS
THEY ARE BY END OF DAY TODAY.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN PATIENTS THERE
QUITE YET.
THERE WERE 68 HOSPITAL BEDS
INCLUDING THE SUM OF TEN ICU
UNITS.
THEY WILL BE ACTUALLY ACCEPTING
COVID-19 PATIENTS WHICH IS
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE’VE SEEN
THAT THESE OTHER TEMPORARY
HOSPITALS.
AT THE SAME TIME, AN
ANNOUNCEMENT IS OPENING UP AT
THE TENNIS CENTER IN QUEENS.
A TEMPORARY HOSPITAL WITH SOME
350 HOSPITAL BEDS.
MAYOR BILL de BLASIO SPEAKING
JUST MOMENTS AGO.
>> FOLKS AFFLICTED BY
CORONAVIRUS, HELP THEM TO
SURVIVE AND RECOVER AND GO HOME
AND SPECIFICALLY HELPING
PATIENTS WHO COME THROUGH
ELMHURST HOSPITAL.
>> THERE ARE 75,000 CORONAVIRUS
CASES IN NEW YORK, SOME 332
DEATHS IN THE LAST 34 HOURS
INCLUDING THE FIRST DEATH OF A
PERSON UNDER THE AGE OF 18.
BUT HELP IS ON THE WAY JUST
TALKING ABOUT A THOUSAND NURSES
COMING, 25050 AMBULANCES ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY TO HELP
NEW YORK.